[Musique]
une annonce d'intérêt public
si je peux sur le port du masque et la
saturation en oxygène
ceci sur mon doigt enregistre la
saturation en oxygène de mon sang et mon rythme cardiaque
ce chiffre supérieur
est la saturation en oxygène tout ce qui se
situe entre 94 et 100 est tout à fait normal
je n'ai pas de respiration  conditions donc pour
moi, il se situe autour de 99.
les deux nombres sont ma fréquence cardiaque,
tout ce qui est au-dessus de 100 est trop rapide et le mien
est rapide parce que je suis énervé de
devoir enregistrer cette vidéo
maintenant je vais mettre un masque  sur quelque chose
que je vois régulièrement
pendant que je travaille en tant que chirurgien et je
vais vous montrer qu'en fait
ce nombre de saturation en oxygène ne change pas les
masques n'ont pas la capacité de réduire
votre oxygène
qui est médicalement faux arrêtez de faire des
trucs
arrêtez  écouter les gens qui
inventent des choses et arrêtez d'en faire un
problème politique les
masques vous aident à vous protéger et à protéger les
autres
si on vous dit de les porter, alors arrêtez d'
être
égoïste c'est un masque de niveau p100, il est similaire
à un n  95
99 [ __ ] de pour cent
[Musique]
Salut, je m'appelle Emily et j'ai
un asthme modéré à sévère étant donné la période de l'
année,
je l'ai contrôlé avec deux médicaments
et j'utilise également un inhalateur de secours et
j'aimerais vous montrer quelque chose
pour mon  ma propre sécurité je possède un oxymètre de pouls
mon niveau actuel est de 99 d'
oxygène c'est le masque que je porte 12
à 14 heures par jour à mon travail de barman
vérifions mon taux d'oxymétrie
passons à quelque chose d'un peu plus
amusant c'est un kn-95  vérifions à nouveau mon
taux d'oxymétrie
99 oh vous pensiez que c'était
fini c'est un masque de niveau p100, il est similaire
à un n95
99 [ __ ] de pour cent en d'autres termes si
quelqu'un comme moi avec des problèmes respiratoires
peut porter ces trois masques
tout au long de la journée et avoir  le même
taux d'oxymétrie, alors quelqu'un sans
problèmes respiratoires n'a pas d'autre excuse
pour ne pas porter de masque autre que sa propre
motivation
égoïste et sa façon d'être sans empathie
[Musique]
salut je m'appelle jay je suis une infirmière autorisée
je suis aussi un humain qui  a une respiration
système ory je porte ce capteur d'oxymétrie de pouls
pour mesurer ma saturation
en oxygène dans ma perfusion de pression artérielle
je porte un masque de procédure et à la
fin d'un quart de travail de 12 heures, je
porte donc ce masque à
peu près régulièrement pendant 12 heures  comme
vous pouvez le voir,
ma saturation en oxygène est de 100%
sur 100
je parle longuement avec cette masse mon
oxygène ne change pas je suis sur roon air
c'est un masque j'ai maintenant deux
masques chirurgicaux sur
la saturation en oxygène est de retour dans ma ligne de base
de 97
98 jusqu'à 100 pour masquer
Jason à nouveau j'ai toujours le capteur post-oxymétrie
sur
la saturation en oxygène 100 était une bonne
forme d'onde
clairement cela n'empêche pas l'
échange de gaz
trois masques chirurgicaux je ne me sens pas
essoufflé
100 donc je porte maintenant un  canule nasale
sans
oxygène attaché mais la raison pour laquelle cela ressemble à
ça est parce qu'elle mesure la
production de dioxyde de carbone des marées comme vous
pouvez le voir ma plage normale est de
42 bien euh dans la plage acceptable mais je
vais aussi avoir une masse un
mettons un let's p  ut trois masques
car certaines personnes pensent que
cela provoque une rétention de co2 pour une
raison quelconque,
j'ai maintenant trois masques chirurgicaux je
mesure
ma saturation en oxygène et mon co2 mon
co2 dans le titre
comme vous pouvez le voir mon intérieur de co2 est de 41
bien dans un  plage acceptable ma
saturation en oxygène
pas d'oxygène supplémentaire je suis toujours à
l'air ambiant normal
c'est 100 portez votre masque
vous n'avez aucune raison de ne pas porter de
masque
du tout
[Musique]
vous